après trois ans et demi d'un feuilleton
riche en rebondissements le royaume uni
fait enfin sombre exceed ce vendredi
londres se donne jusqu'à la fin de
l'année pour renégocier ses relations
avec l'union européenne bien des choses
ont été dites à ce sujet les dix plaies
d'egypte devait s'abattre sur l'économie
britannique pourtant rien de cela ne
s'est produit en tout cas pour l'instant
plutôt le contraire mais pour combien de
temps on voit ça tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir bonsoir aka
soyez le bienvenu alors jacques
stéphanie doit-on être pessimiste ou
optimiste à propos du bric site que
réserve-t-il aux britanniques
alors oui effectivement les adversaires
du bric site avait commencé à parler de
toute une série de cataclysmes et de
catastrophes qui allait se produire
et il l'avait fait de manière assez
consciente pour d'une certaine manière
terroriser les lecteurs britanniques ce
qui était d'ailleurs très mal le
connaître et ce qu'on a pu appeler le le
projet peur n'a pas du tout fonctionné
alors il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui
faisant il ya de cela une dizaine de
jours en réalité le fonds monétaire
international a publié des prévisions de
croissance et comme par hasard on voit
que la croissance de la grande bretagne
est prévu pour les deux prochaines
années à un niveau supérieur de la
croissance de l'union européenne
donc voilà il va falloir effectivement
maintenant être un peu plus sérieux et
regarder quels sont les atouts mais
aussi peut-être et faiblesses de
l'économie britannique
alors jacques avant d'aller plus loin je
vous propose de voir ce qu'en pensent
les français que nous avons a rencontré
de ce break site qui se fait enfin leur
fait-il peur ou au contraire à ce que ça
les intéresse
écoutez ils l'ont voté donc à partir du
moment où c'est ce qu'ils ont décidé
autant que ça se fasse le plus vite
possible
c'est dommage on les a rappelé que nous
tant pis pour eux mais c'est dommage
c'est une sortie au forceps en fait
l'europe c'est
se construit lentement difficilement des
fois et perdra membres s'est jamais
avantageux je pense qu'ils auraient
aussi eu le temps de refaire un
référendum pendant ces trois ans parce
que je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas du
tout une décision qui fait l'unanimité
la barre j'attends de voir
parce que à chaque fois ça a été reculée
reculer recul et donc j'attends là
peut-être la surprise de dernière minute
je pense que ça se fera pas tout de
suite à la non pas parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de sujets à régler certains
disent que ça peut être avantageux il ya
pas mal d'entreprises que l'on soit en
train de réfléchir à s'installer ici par
exemple moi mais ma boîte qui américaine
à la grosse partie est en angleterre est
de plus en plus c'est finalement les
embauches maintenance fond apparaît donc
pour nous mon petit domaine ses victimes
au hasard cela pas mal fermé les
frontières ça c'est quoi c'est revenir
en arrière
on a bien vu qu'il y avait des bienfaits
rouvrir les frontières à faire des pâtes
commerciaux internationaux etc
je vois pas ce qu'on peut gagner je
pense que l'angleterre étant un grand
pays
ils vont pas s'effondrer aussi
facilement que ça avec le commonwealth
derrière eux je pense que s'en sortiront
très bien donc on sait jamais je veux
dire s'il ya des bons accords avec
l'europe si ils ont des gros d'accord
avec ces américains ils peuvent très
bien s'en sortir voire pourquoi pas
mieux que l'europe
votre réaction jacques alors on entend
des choses qui sont très diverses mais
qui peuvent se résumer en d'abord oui
les gens sont non pas inquiet mais bon
ils ont conscience que ça va être un
petit peu compliqué bien sûr il ya aussi
les gens qui d'une certaine manière font
de confiance dans le royaume uni qui
voit là c'est une grande économie n'est
pas trop la question du commonwealth
mais c'est vrai c'est une grande
économie et elle a de la ressource a
tout à fait les capacités de résister
aux chocs du break 6 et puis il ya ceux
qui visiblement continue de penser qu'il
y aurait une majorité de britanniques y
serait opposée au brésil alors que l'on
sait maintenant que c'est très
exactement l'un vertes comme a pu le
montrer
l'élection générale qui a eu lieu au
mois de décembre alors jacques ce break
site
est-ce qu'il a déjà provoqué les
catastrophes qu'on nous avait prédite
en ce qui concerne la production
britannique le pib mais vous savez on en
avait déjà parlé de l'ordre de
l'émission sur le protectionnisme est
bien quand on regarde les courbes on
voit que le pib de la grande bretagne
il augmente à peu près au même rythme
que le pib de l'allemagne même là à un
petit peu plus vite que le pib de
l'allemagne
nettement plus vite que le pib de la
france je le redis ce sont les dernières
prévisions du fonds monétaire
international qui donne une croissance
de 1,4 pour cent pour la grande bretagne
mais plutôt de 1,2 pour cent pour
l'union européenne est un petit peu
moins par exemple pour l'allemagne donc
non ce qui est prévu pour les prochaines
années
c'est que l'économie britannique va
continuer de croître et de croître plus
vite que l'union européenne alors on
parle beaucoup jacques de l'impact
évidemment du bric site sur le chômage
est ce que ce dernier va augmenter ou
diminuer selon vous alors effectivement
le chômage avait d'ailleurs été un des
grands arguments pour le break 6 ce que
l'on constate c'est qu'en fait depuis
2010 le chômage en grande-bretagne
baisse à peu près au même rythme qu'à
baisser le chômage en allemagne voyez il
ya une très grande différence avec la
courbe de l'italie où la courbe de la
france alors ce qu'il faut dire
maintenant en perspective c'est que le
bric sida évidemment réduire l'entrée
des travailleurs européens en grande
bretagne donc ça veut dire que les
entreprises britanniques vont devoir
embaucher des britanniques
ça c'est un bon point pour l'emploi
deuxièmement comme les salaires ont été
fortement augmenté le salaire minimum a
été augmenté de 6,6 pour cent au début
de cette année donc on a une situation
qui est plutôt favorable aux ouvriers
britanniques
le problème d'ailleurs c'est qu'elle est
peut-être tellement favorables
qu'aujourd'hui ceux qui s'inquiètent le
plus du bric si ce sont certaines
entreprises en particulier les
entreprises de main d'oeuvre alors jacky
bios des salaires est beaucoup moins de
chômage dit aussi inflation n'est ce pas
un risque au royaume uni pour la
compétitivité de son économie
alors vous avez tout à fait raison parce
que ça si vous voulez c'est un cocktail
quand vous avez très peu de chômage
quand vous avez des salaires ils
commencent à augmenter fortement
eh bien on aboutir ce qu'on appelle dans
notre jargon d'économiste
je suis désolé je suis économiste et
c'est ce qu'on appelle justement
action qui est poussé par les coups ou
qos poche alors il faut d'abord savoir
que le taux d'inflation
il était déjà assez différent mais
depuis 2009 2010 vous voyez là il ya eu
par exemple en 2013 et 2014 d'une hausse
de l'inflation nettement au-dessus du
taux d'inflation qui était celui de
l'allemagne ou de l'angleterre est par
contre ce qui est intéressant c'est que
depuis le vote sur le break in donc le
référendum de juin 2016
eh bien l'inflation en grande-bretagne
est à peu près au même niveau que celles
en allemagne par contre elle est
nettement plus forte qu'en france
alors jacques je reviens à la charge ce
surcroît d'inflation sur tout ce qui
devait accentuer ces prochaines années
ne pourrait-il pas mettre l'économie
britannique en mauvaise posture quand
même effectivement c'est ce qu'on
appelle le problème de la contrainte
extérieure est là vous avez tout à fait
raison d'en parler quand on a une hausse
des coûts si on a le même taux de change
que ses voisins on a un problème que la
grande bretagne a toujours refusé
absolument de faire partie de la zone
euro elle a toujours voulu conserver la
livre sterling est là ce qu'on voit
c'est que qu'est-ce qu'a provoquée le
référendum de juin 2007
magna provoquer une dépréciation de la
livre why et elle commence à baisser
avec les premiers sondages sur les
résultats du référendum et puis tant
qu'à le référendum elle tombe vraiment
et aujourd'hui on constate qu'il ya eu
une dépréciation d'environ 20 % du taux
de change
et cette dépréciation elle est plus que
suffisante pour couvrir les écarts de
coûts les écarts d'inflation entre les
pays de l'union européenne et la grande
bretagne donc d'une certaine manière
c'est le fait d'avoir conservé sa propre
monnaie qui la donnent à la grande
bretagne la flexibilité nécessaire pour
résister à un possible retour de
l'inflation
alors est-ce que ça a eu des
conséquences sur les importations et
exportations britanniques
oui il ya une petite conséquences et là
encore si vous voulez il faut bien
regarder ce qui se passe jusqu'en 2013 à
peu près bon il ya les exportations et
les importations font à peu près au même
niveau
après 2013 jusqu'à 2016
eh bien les exportations sont moins 20
montre moins rapidement que les
importations donc le déficit commercial
évidemment augmente et puis à partir du
moment où on à la dépréciation de la
livre sterling qui donc survient dans la
deuxième moitié de 2016 et surtout
l'année 2010 elle est bien on voit que
les deux courbes commence à se resserrer
et on peut donc penser que d'ici les
prochaines années eh bien elles vont à
nouveau se recouper et qu'il n'y aura
plus de déficit commercial en grande
bretagne
alors quelles sont les perspectives de
l'économie britannique dans ce contexte
du break site
au niveau des perspectives d'abord il
faut parler de l'investissement on en
avait déjà parlé dans l'émission sur le
protectionnisme
l'investissement n'a pas été affecté par
le vote de 2016
par contre les incertitudes extrêmement
importante qu'il y avait eu en 2019
avant qu'on ne savait pas est ce que le
break site aurait lieu est-ce qu'il
serait peut être annulée et c'est bon ça
ça a déstabilisé les entreprises et là
il ya une chute des investissements en
particulier des investissements
étrangers en grande bretagne par contre
depuis que l'on est sûr que le bric site
va avoir lieu vers depuis en fait que
boris johnson a gagné la bataille des
législatives en décembre
eh bien on voit un retour de confiance
important dans les entreprises donc ça
c'est un premier point
le deuxième point qu'il faut avoir à
l'esprit c'est le fait que la structure
des importations et des exportations
britanniques
elle est pas réellement centré sur
l'union européenne regardez c'est quand
même important alors ce sont des
chiffres qui datent de 2016
mais envoyer que déjà à cette époque là
donc avant le les effets du vote sur le
brésil est bien les exportations d un
année 43% vers l'union européenne et que
le reste du monde
c'était pratiquement 60% alors c'est
moins important pour les importations
et là il ya une raison très simple c'est
qu'il ya beaucoup d'importation en
grande bretagne qui sont ce qu'on
appelle des importations de proximité
exemple classique c'est le bacon du
petit déjeuner anglais qui est acheté au
danemark est essentiellement bons mets
donc qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire que évidemment la grande bretagne
commerce peut-être plus avec le reste du
monde qu'avec l'union européenne et
c'est encore plus évident quand on
regarde la liste des principaux clients
de la grande bretagne
eh bien vous voyez les états unis font
19% alors que le total de l'allemagne et
de la france est quand même les deux
premières économies de l'union
européenne n'arrive pas à ce niveau là
et même si on ajoute l'italie troisième
économie de l'union européenne ben non
on ne va pas y arriver
donc ça veut dire effectivement que on a
une économie qui est plutôt tourné sur
le reste du monde que sur l'union
européenne et c'est pour ça que d'une
certaine manière le président fait sens
alors jacques selon vous pas de
catastrophe à l'horizon non pas de
catastrophe
et tant pis pour tous ces gens qui
prédisaient le pire pour la grande
bretagne
non la grande-bretagne ne va pas
canettes connaître de catastrophe avec
le break 6 merci jacques en tout cas de
votre analyse sur ses explications qui
font réfléchir merci à vous merci